>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Kenneth Nyirady: Good afternoon.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome
to the Library of Congress
and to this event, Saving
Libraries During a Time of War.
The Hill Museum and
Manuscript Libraries [inaudible]
to preserve manuscripts threatened
by war and cultural trafficking.
My name is Kenneth Nyirady.
I'm a reference specialist
in the European Division.
The Library is pleased
to sponsor today's event,
and we do so in partnership with the
Embassy of the Republic of Malta,
the Embassy of Italy, the
Italian Cultural Institute
and the European Union
National Institutes of Culture.
We are also pleased to have as our
guest speaker Dr. Daniel K. Gullo,
the Joseph F. McCullough Curator
of the Malta Study Center.
In just a minute, I will ask
our specialists for both Italy
and Malta, Ms. Lucia Wolf,
to introduce the speaker.
Before that, let me say that
the Library of Congress is proud
of its extensive collections
on both Malta and Italy.
If you have any questions
about using these collections,
be sure to contact Ms. Wolf.
We hope you enjoy Dr.
Gullo's presentation
and that you will come back
to use our collections.
I thank all who have
made this event possible.
Of course, I must ask you to
please silence all cell phones
and portable electronic devices.
This presentation will be webcast,
and there will be a question
and answer period at the end.
And by asking a question, you're
giving the library permission
to webcast your image
and your voice.
I now ask Ms. Wolf to the podium.
>> Lucia Wolf: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
I'm Lucia Wolf.
I am thrilled to have you
here today for this event
that touches upon a topic
that is vital for the future
of libraries and museums.
Libraries are not static
institutions.
They shift with the transformations
of society and cultural communities
of which society is made.
In spite of changes,
library's missions
and goals remain fundamentally
unchanged.
The preservation of cultural
heritage for future generations
and the promotion of
new cultural venues.
As the writer, [inaudible]
poignantly said,
"Libraries are systems in which
the various eras organize the
[inaudible] as well as
the [inaudible] text."
Food for thought.
Before introducing our speaker,
I would like to acknowledge
the presence of some guests.
Well, he was going to be here,
but I will just say it anyway.
His Excellency, the Ambassador of
the Republic of Malta [inaudible].
Hello. I'm still coming [inaudible].
Hello there.
Thank you very much.
It's an honor to have you here.
And Mr. Ambassador, thank you for
your company and for the company
of your diplomats from the
embassy, Mr. [inaudible]
and Mr. Peter Heely
[assumed spelling].
I would also like to thank the
Honorable Ambassador Peter Selfridge
[assumed spelling], maybe not
yet here, Chief of Protocol
at the U.S. Department of State.
Thank you to Dr. Constance
Whiteside for being here.
Thank you very much.
Dr. Constance Whiteside is a senior
outreach officer of the delegation
of the European Union
to the United States.
Thank you, my friend [inaudible],
the cultural attache of the Embassy
of Italy in Washington, D.C. I would
like to ask the Ambassador for --
at the end of the Q and A if you
would like to make the conclusions
and [inaudible] wants
to say a few words
after the Ambassador maybe also
about the program about the --
okay, finally I need to
acknowledge Dr. John [inaudible],
the Director for Scholarly and
Educational Programs of the Library
of Congress' national
and international outreach office
whose support was essential
for holding this event
in this beautiful venue.
Thank you.
Incidentally, I would like to bring
your attention to a small display
that I have tried to curate a
little bit in a hurry because I
like researching the collections
very widely, and I get lost
in the research, but back there we
have some rare books, some maps,
Ambassador, and anyone else
you're welcome to go in at the end
of the lecture and take a look.
The items out there are about
Malta or published in Malta,
and in different languages.
So now I will introduce
Dr. Gullo, Gullo, Gullo.
Dr. Daniel Gullo is the Assistant
Director of the Hill Museum
and Manuscript Library and the
Joseph S. [inaudible] Curator
of the Malta Study Center.
Dr. Gullo apparently holds the
position that I have just described,
the [inaudible] curator of the Malta
Study Center at the Hill Museum
and Manuscript Library
at St. John's University
in Collegeville, Minnesota.
He received his Bachelor's degree --
Bachelor's of Arts from the
University of Wisconsin Madison
in history and Spanish, Master's
of art from the University
of Toronto in Medieval Studies.
We have something in common there.
And Master's in Arts and Theology
from St. John's University
in Collegeville, and his Ph.D.
from the University
of Chicago in history.
He has held the position of
lecturer in Medieval History
at Northeastern Illinois University
and Assistant Professor in history
and geography at Columbus
State University.
His specialty is the history
of monasticism and book culture
in late Medieval and
early modern Europe.
I'm sorry, I'm reading,
a big agitated --
with a particular interest in
the history of religious orders
and the kingdom of Aragorn during
the 15th and 16th centuries.
Dr. Gullo, the floor is yours.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Daniel Gullo: Good afternoon,
and thank you all for coming
on this exceptionally wonderful
day here in Washington,
D.C. I've been coming to D.C.
now regularly for the last couple
of years and staying many different
neighborhoods across the city,
and I can tell you that
I've become more enamored
with Washington as time goes by.
I want to thank Dr. Ambassador
[inaudible] of the Republic of Malta
and in her absence, Dr. Patricia
Borge [assumed spelling],
for providing me with
the opportunity
to represent their
wonderful country.
This is our third partnership
over the last two years,
and I hope we can continue working
together for many years to come.
I would also like to briefly
express my sincere thanks
to Ambassador Armando [inaudible]
and the Embassy of Italy,
the Italian Cultural Institute, the
European Union National Institutes
for Culture and the Library
of Congress for organizing
and sponsoring this important series
on the need to preserve culture
and libraries during
times of war and conflict.
Now my discussion today will center
on the history and activities
of the Hill Museum and
Manuscript Library and its 50 years
to preserve culture across
the world to first microfilm
and then digitize endangered library
conductions, the Multi-Study Center,
as part of HMML has contributed to
this effort for 43 of the 50 years
of its existence and
to my knowledge,
remains the longest
self-sustained continuing effort
to photographically
preserve manuscript culture
in the world today.
I will discuss the historical
legacy of HMML and how it emerged
in response to the
destruction of libraries,
particular Medieval manuscripts in
World War II and then quickly turn
to our current preservation efforts,
which will include not only some
of the older microfilm history
but also our current
digital photography.
I will also end with a brief display
of our new digital collection,
which we have recently released
online in August, virtual HMML,
which will be sharing our
preservations with the world.
I hope to leave plenty of time
for discussion because I think
in many instances a
discussion of HMML is best done
with your questions, and there
are many questions that can arise
from the preservation of libraries.
If I might indulge a little
brief personal history,
I'd like to place the context
of HMML's organizational efforts
within Benedictine history and in
particular Benedictine monasticism
in Europe so that we can understand
how St. John's [inaudible]
in Central Minnesota became the
leading pioneer of microfilm
and digitization of endangered
library collections in the world.
My first story, and I will
limit it to two brief stories,
begins with my own research on the
Benedictine Monastery of [inaudible]
and the efforts of two 18th
century historians, one a jesuit,
Raymundo Diosdado Caballero, who
was living in Rome and the other,
the Augustinian Francisco Mendez
living in Madrid were attempting
to uncover the early printing
history of Spain of the 15th century
as they engaged in a historical
debate at the close of the 18th.
They were particularly
interested in the printing press
that [inaudible] operated by
[inaudible] between 1499 and 1500.
[Inaudible] not only boasted one
of the finest Medieval manuscript
collections in Europe at the time
but also one of the best
rare book collections.
It was also one of the most
important early prolific centers
of printing at the end
of the 15th century.
Now being good historians, both
of them, unable to travel wrote
to the archivist at Montserrat,
Friar Benet Ribas i Calaf
who was asked to provide them
any type of information he could
from their manuscripts and archives
regarding the printing press.
Friar Benet who was an exceptional
historian himself dug deep
into the manuscript archive
and actually found the original
contracts that were written
by Garcia [inaudible]
and Johann Luschner,
the printer who had taken
his press to the [inaudible].
He found those documents, and he
first transcribed and sent them
to [inaudible] in Rome and later
again to Madrid to Francisco Mendez.
Those two historians in
turn printed selections
of those letters [inaudible]
in different versions
in their own respective books.
The fact that both historians
recorded distinct original
transcriptions that is a copy of
original documents provided me
as a young scholar with
this amazing opportunity
if I could only find those
original manuscripts.
My dissertation would
have been complete
in much less time than it was.
Sadly, however, Montserrat's
library was destroyed.
Between 1808 and 1812, major battles
took place during the Peninsula War
and Napoleonic troops burned the
library to the ground in 1812.
And as a result, over
10,000 manuscripts
and early printed books
went up in flames
and countless manuscript
archival records no longer exist
and were destroyed.
Everything that we know about the
printing press of Johann Luschner
and its operations all
of the manuscripts recorded those
activities are now only preserved
in copies found in
18th century books.
The second Benedictine one is
probably more famous to you.
These very famous pictures,
of course, of the destruction
of Montecassino from 1944.
It was at this time, of course,
that something really
remarkable was happening.
Libraries, of course, in Europe
during World Wars had been
vulnerable to destruction.
One only has to remember what
happened to the University Library
in [inaudible] which was
destroyed in World War I.
Here there was an interesting
debate that took place in 1944
when two German officers
showed up at the [inaudible]
and basically begged the monks to
relocate their library in order
to preserve it because of the
threat of allied bombing raids.
Maltese archivist librarian at
the time, Father Mauro Inguanez
who was born in the
city of [inaudible],
argued that the library
should not be moved.
In fact, he was very
worried because of the rumors
that the Germans had been
confiscating libraries
and deporting them to
Germany never to return again.
His [inaudible] at the time, Tommaso
Leccisotti, argued on the contrary
and said that we must move them,
that he wasn't really confident
in allied bombing, particularly
because of the evidence
of what had taken place
in the southern Italian
peninsula at the time.
Fortunately for us, the
group got together, the monks
and their chapter, and they voted
to move the library to [inaudible]
in 1944 and as a result, the state
and Monastic library that was housed
at Montecassino was preserved.
Father Maurio Inguanez was,
of course, extremely happy
about the preservation
of the library
and the stroke of luck that he had.
In fact, we singularly owe
him the existence of the ashes
of [inaudible] which he had put
into his own duffle bag and hidden
in a secret part of the library
and then transported them
to the British Embassy
after the war.
This is a fun little story to add.
The destruction of the libraries
we can see here, of course,
was a great tragedy, although
the books were preserved.
Father Maurio Inguanez left to
the United States to raise funds
for the construction of a new
library and then went to Malta
in 1948 where he became the Chief
Librarian of the Royal Library
of Malta until his death in 1955,
a point which I will
return to in a few minutes.
It is actually a result of the
destruction of Montecassino
and its effect upon
Benedictines throughout the world
that we can probably trace
the history of the Hill Museum
and Manuscript Library, which
was the result of a conversation
which took place in Rome in
Italy probably in the late 1950's
or early 1960's between Father
Barry Colman and the Pontif.
It was at this time that it was
decided that Father Barry Colman
or Father Colman Barry
would actually try to engage
in the process of microfilming all
of the Benedictine
manuscript libraries in Europe.
Now it's not as if these type
of projects were unheard of.
We already had the
Knights of Columbus working
on microfilming the Vatican
Library and the Lutheran Churches
of America had begun filming
the works of Martin Luther
and the early Protestants
in Germany and Austria.
But there was no organization
that had dedicated itself
to the preservation of
small and remote libraries
that were vulnerable not only to the
fact that the libraries might close
but also to the fact that these
libraries were often neglected
for conservation purposes.
Father Colman at this time enlisted
his -- to help with this endeavor.
His [inaudible] Oliver Kapsner
who was at this time the librarian
at Catholic University of America
and also research librarian
at the Library of Congress.
Father Oliver Kapsner had
firsthand witness of the destruction
of Europe having been a
chaplain in World War II
in the European theater
of operations.
I believe he was at
the Battle of the Bulge
and therefore could see
firsthand the greatest destruction
of European culture that took
place during that campaign.
These two gentlemen, of
course, first went to Italy.
It was a logical place for them to
begin their preservation efforts,
but initially their
work was frustrated
and Montecassino did not open
their doors to their preservation.
Instead, they went to
Austria and later to Germany.
Austria was a obvious place to go.
Not only did it have
some of the greatest
and most beautiful Benedictine
libraries in the world,
but at this time it was sandwiched
between both the Warsaw
Pact and NATO.
Austria was vulnerable to invasion
because it wouldn't immediately
trigger the NATO alliance.
You have to remember this was,
of course, taking place in 1964
and 1965 at the height
of the Cold War.
And it was at this time in 1965 when
the [inaudible] opened his doors
to Father Kapsner and began
the microfilm project,
which has now been going
strong for over 50 years now
that we are using digital
technology.
This early work that was undertaken
by Father Oliver Kapsner in Austria
and Germany lasted
until the early 1970's.
And it was at this time that the
then director, Dr. Julian Plant,
envisioned HMML's work
into something much bigger.
What began as the monastic
manuscript microfilm project quickly
became the Hill Monastic
Manuscript Library.
And it was at this time in
discussions first with Ethiopia
with Emperor [inaudible] and then
in Spain and then, of course,
with Malta that the Hill
Museum began a worldwide effort
to preserve endangered
library collections.
The first one, of course,
that expanded beyond Europe
was actually in Ethiopia.
His holiness [inaudible] and Emperor
[inaudible] were very worried
about the state of Ethiopian
libraries in particular
in the cultural trafficking
of objects.
They were also worried about
an uprising and some form
of communist revolution in Ethiopia,
and therefore thought it imperative
to start preserving their
libraries before it was too late.
It must be remembered that in 1973
Spain, of course, was still dealing
with the idea of what might
happen if Franco had passed away.
Given the complexity and
violence of the Spanish Civil War,
destruction of the Spanish cultural
heritage was in obvious peril.
Malta, of course, in 1973 was
going through its own transition.
It was strategically
located in the Mediterranean
and with the conflicts
going on in the world,
one would not know what would happen
if it became an object of conflict
as a competition between the
Warsaw states and also NATO.
To kind of put this
into perspective,
you can imagine what was going
through the people's minds
at HMML in the early 1970's.
The University of Complutense
in Madrid between 1936
and 1939 lost 80,000 books,
80,000 in one single institution.
Malta itself received more
bombs between 1940 and 1943
in a geographical area than
any other place in Europe.
What might happen to those library
collections if war began again?
To kind of put all of this into
perspective, I'm going to focus
on a few unique objects,
which thanks to the efforts
of HMML we now can actually trace.
One of them was a microfilm
of this 18th century Bible.
It's actually not a complete
Bible but selections photographed
in the 1970's known as EMML 7014.
This Bible disappeared only to
resurface several years later
at the National Library of Norway.
And thanks to our microfilming
process,
you can see I've actually flipped
into the modern era already.
Thanks to our microfilming process,
we are actually able to identify
and locate this Bible and
create a strong connection
between its original owners in
Ethiopia and also maintain its place
in the National Library of Norway.
Therefore, what began as a project
to preserve cultural heritage helped
us actually locate trafficked --
illegally trafficked manuscripts.
This is something that
continues to today.
One can only turn to Ebay
and see the cultural heritage
from around the world, Ethiopia,
Syria, Egypt, the Middle East,
Afghanistan, the market for
manuscripts is ever increasing
and because of their uniqueness ,
hey are objects of
desire on the market.
A second example which I
find even more interesting
to my mind is this really
unique cover that you can see
from our 2010 newsletter,
Illuminations.
You can see here an the
11th century Latin Bible
that was produced in Spain.
It's remarkable because this
Bible was actually destroyed
in the [inaudible] Library in 1937.
What you see in color is the
one fragment that remains
from this very rare
[inaudible] manuscript.
In 2010, Dr. Hugh Hone [assumed
spelling] contacted HMML
and wondered, "Did we have a
microfilm of this manuscript?"
Which seemed a bit odd because
we hadn't actually done any work
in the 1930's, but he
wondered if somehow
or another there was
anything that we had.
There were some plates floating
around, but he really wanted
to know was there something.
And in fact what ended up happening
is in 1979 unbeknownst to all of us,
Dr. Julian Plant had
engaged in this process
of buying individual microfilms to
support HMML's overall collections,
trying to find copies of
all of the [inaudible]
so that people could
study the manuscripts
and not just the plates at HMML.
In so doing, he actually purchased
a film from the [inaudible]
in Madridin 1979, which
was Kodak's 31 [inaudible]
which was taken before
the Spanish Civil War
and housed in the national library.
The National Library of
Madrid or the National Library
of Spain sent us there one
unique [inaudible] instead
of making a duplicate.
So we have the only microfilm of
the world of this lost manuscript,
which was now being
able to be studied
and put together with the original.
My third and final example which
I can smile at my colleage,
Dr. Karen Ruff, over there to the
left is actually now found in Malta.
This, of course, is
a digital manuscript,
which we photographed
earlier this year.
This manuscript was discovered
in a drawer upstairs and found
within a collection of
manuscript fragments donated
to the cathedral archives by the
family of Friar Maurio Inguanez
who remember was the librarian
and archivist of Montecassino.
This very rare 11th or 12th
century manuscript includes
within it a unique
blend of Beneventan
and Carolingian paleography.
And it is to my mind probably no
doubt made provisionally at least,
provisionally made at the
[inaudible] of Montecassino
and brought to Malta by Father
Inguanez after he went to the island
in 1948 probably as part of
maintaining and preserving some link
to his [inaudible]
after he left and went
to the National Library of Malta.
From these extremely humble
beginnings, we can actually think
about 50 years of preserving
the patrimony of humanity.
On over four continents
now, the Hill Museum
and Manuscript Library has been
preserving collections throughout
the world.
Today we are working on
four distinct continents,
and what I would like to
take a moment to speak
about our culture efforts first
looking at those in the Middle East
and then in Africa at
the [inaudible] and Malta
because all together
they encompass our effort
to preserve endangered collections.
And so we've just added
one in Washington,
D.C. in the upper left hand corner
thanks to the Catholic University
of America who last week
opened their collection to us
to help preserve the border of
Malta's collection at their library.
They're a very beautiful
and wonderful collection.
I'm going to begin
with a brief discussion
of our preservation efforts
in Syria, which began in 2004
with an inheritance of a project
begun by Brigham Young University.
Our work in these libraries went
from 2004 to 2012 focusing largely
on the collections
and homes in Olimpo
but also few other smaller
collections in the country.
These projects of course have
been suspended, but in addition
to our work there, several
of these collections
at least we believe might
have been relocated.
We simply do not know at this time.
What we do know is that we have
preserved nearly 3000 manuscripts
which may or may not have been
destroyed from the city of Olimpo,
the surrounding villages and homes.
All of these collections are
now being kept digitally at HMML
and remain an important
cultural repository
for the work not only done
by the librarians at the time
but by the continuing efforts of
our catalogers throughout the world.
A second collection,
of course, is Iraq.
We began filming in Iraq in 2003 and
filming and digitization continues
to take place primarily in
the city of [inaudible].
Our preservation efforts began
in Mosul and in [inaudible],
two cities which of
course now remain
under occupation by
the Islamic state.
We did work in other cities
in Iraq and also in Baghdad,
but primarily our effort is
focused on the Christian communities
which have been located in
their endangered collections
in northwestern Iraq in
the province of Ninevah.
This effort is largely being carried
out by Father Najib
who's a Dominican
who now is continuing
work in [inaudible].
He's a rather remarkable man because
he spends his mornings taking care
of the refugees who are living
in [inaudible] and his afternoons
and evenings as you can see here
preparing these extremely beautiful
manuscripts for digitization.
This project is being
done in concert
with the Centre Numerique
des Manuscrits Orientaux,
the [inaudible] project
and as I'll show you
in just a few moments it has done
some of the remarkable digitization
in both Turkey and in
Iraq over the last decade.
A third major project, our largest
project, is taking place currently
in Mali in the city of [inaudible].
That is because in 2012 there
was the Taureg Rebellion
which invaded the city.
Many of you might be familiar
with the recently published book,
the [inaudible] Librarians of
Timbuktu, which recounts the efforts
of the local population of
librarians to transport over 50,000,
some even say up to 300,000
manuscripts from Timbuktu
to [inaudible] in order to
preserve those manuscripts.
Now, the Hill Museum and
Manuscript Library has been working
with several organizations
in Mali and in [inaudible].
Here you can see the wonderful
chess that were created
to ship these manuscripts
to the capital.
We have now 12 cameras operating
in the city funded by a variety
of different organizations
including the Arcadia Fund,
the Prince Claus Fund, the
Juma Al-Majid Center of Culture
and Heritage all working
with SAVAMA-DCI
to preserve these manuscript
collections.
We are, of course, working
in Malta, and I know Malta
of course is not currently
underneath any formal threat of war
or invasion, but it still suffers
from the tremendous effects
of World War II upon the island.
And here I am speaking
of the Notarial archieves
in St. Christopher
Street in Valetta.
The remarkable effort being led
by Dr. Jonah Bella [assumed
spelling] the Notoarial Research
Council to basically help restore
literally thousands and thousands
and thousands of manuscripts dating
back to the 15th century in Malta
which were buried underneath
the city and forgotten as a part
of their attempt to preserve those
records during the bombing raids
of Valetta in world War II.
The Hill Museum and Manuscript
Library pioneered a project
with the Notarial archieves between
2010 and 2014, and the register
which you see here, register 202,
which is a 16th century Notarial
document, has shrapnel holes
in it made by 200 pound
bomb dropped by [inaudible]
on top of Valetta in 1943.
So you can actually see those are
the bomb fragments that helped --
that damaged the manuscript.
Thankfully, the European Union
and the European Council have
recently rewarded the Notarial
archives with a significant grant
to not only help preserve these
manuscripts but to catalogue them
and make them available
to the public.
Another major collection in Malta,
which was discovered in 2010
which was part of our work with
the National Archives of Malta
between 2007 and 2015 were
an important collection
of documents located in
[inaudible] at the front of Valetta.
Here in [inaudible] 2010 literally
probably somewhere around 10,000
to 15,000 manuscript documents were
found at the bottom of a cistern
where they were dumped
or put in order
to protect the documents during
the bombing raids of World War II.
As you can see, here's a beautiful
40 mm [inaudible] which was located
about 50 meters away from where
these documents were found.
Obviously, a target for any
German bomber at the time.
These manuscripts were discovered
in 2010 and were in such a state
that the Army, the Maltese
Army needed to be brought
in using chemical suits to remove
the documents from the cistern
and through the efforts of the
National Archives were able
to be cleaned and preserved, and the
Hill Museum and Manuscript Library
and Malta Study Center
helped catalogue
and digitize these records
in the fall of 2015.
Currently in Malta, we
are working with a project
of Fondazzjoni Patrimonju Malti to
help preserve private libraries.
Private libraries are extremely
vulnerable not simply to forms
of war, but in particular
to sell disbursement
or through issues of
climate control.
We will be engaging over
the next three to five years
in the digitization and preservation
of these vast collections
of libraries, primarily the
repositories of noble families.
We're currently working at
the [inaudible] in Valetta
where we have found over 400
manuscripts and 300 archival boxes
with manuscripts dating
from the early 15th century
through the 20th century.
These collections are not
simply Maltese collections
but European collections
as the family --
the [inaudible] family held
important positions in France,
Italy and in the Mediterranean
as Naval captains,
and they chart the history
of the Mediterranean.
One of the most amazing
documents that we were able
to find was this beautiful
collection of Lebanese documents
that were suing the knights
of Malta in the 1730's
to have their cargo restored to them
after it had been illegally seized
in their minds by Maltese
[inaudible].
The [inaudible] family being
quite wise bought the legal suit
from the Lebanese family and
proceeded to win the case in court.
Some 30,000 [inaudible]
were delivered
to the [inaudible] as
part of the process.
This is actually an image as a
part of the legal proceedings
where they're trying to chart
the Maltese ships hitting --
about to capture that poor
Lebanese sailing vessel.
Before I move on, I want to
say that all of this done --
all of the work we've done should
be reminded that every library
that we worked in, whether
it was vulnerable to war
or not remains vulnerable.
We did microfilm the Cologne
State Archives back in the 1980's,
and as a great tragedy, I
believe according to a gas leak,
the Cologne State Archives
collapsed in 2009.
And thanks to our microfilming
efforts,
we preserved the Medieval
collection which by
and large was destroyed during
the collapse of the building.
What does this all mean?
It means a significant amount
for the preserving of culture
of our patrimony or
patrimony of humanity.
Results from our work
in Iraq and Syria alone,
we've preserved ten collections and
nearly 2000 manuscripts in Mosul,
846 manuscripts in Baghdad.
In Aleppo itself, nearly
3000 manuscripts.
Between Iraq and Syria,
8000 manuscripts have
been digitally preserved
that have been vulnerable to war.
If we put that into the larger
context of the Middle East,
if we add Lebanon and
Jerusalem, Turkey and Egypt,
nearly 21,000 manuscripts
dating back
to the middle ages have
been preserved by HMML.
If we think about this in
perspective, what this means
as a repository of
humanity, and I'm sitting here
in probably the world's
greatest repository of knowledge
that there is, we have
36,600 digitized manuscripts
from the Middle East,
which is larger than all
of western libraries combined
in Europe and North America.
If we think about the
Syriac collection alone,
13,500 manuscripts are now being
preserved and catalogued at HMML
where all of the European libraries
and North American
libraries preserve only 3400
within their repositories.
For Islamic culture, the
numbers are no less remarkable.
31,992 manuscripts and growing.
We think we'll have nearly
100,000 manuscripts preserved
in the next five years alone.
It will be the largest collection
of Islamic manuscripts in the world.
Malta is a significant
contributor to this project.
We've been working in Malta since
1973, and as I say, uninterruptedly.
If we think about the cathedral
itself which was largely
in microfilm, 15,000 manuscripts
charting the history of Malta
through the 15th century
through the 20th century
and parish archives had
been preserved by HMML.
This is extremely important because
the Maltese population dispersed
after World War II largely as a
result of the poverty of the country
as it suffered from
the effects of the war.
I had received daily letters
from Maltese, from Australia,
through Canada, through South
America all looking to us
for their parish records in order
to trace their family history.
The National Library of Malta,
nearly 3500 manuscripts.
And you can see from
the digital collection,
we now have 3000 manuscripts
themselves.
This, of course, is a bit deceiving
because we're largely
preserving archival documents
and archival documents
are much larger
than a traditional manuscript.
So if we can think of nearly 21,000
manuscripts, it's probably closer
to 42,000 manuscripts preserved
of Maltese cultural heritage.
It's the largest repository
of Maltese culture outside
of the island in the world.
To this, I can add nearly 90
documents that we preserved
at the Catholic University
of America last week.
So how does this all play
out in our world today?
If this is the mission of HMML,
to make sure that we preserve all
of the culture that we have in
the world regardless of creed,
regardless of place, regardless
of society, these very,
very valuable manuscripts, the
Hill Museum and Manuscript Library
of course located in
central Minnesota,
which is a wonderfully
safe place for one to be
in the northern part
of the United States.
If you wish to come visit us,
it is one of the most
beautiful locations also.
St. John's University and St.
John's Abbey is great in the summer.
Maybe February is a
little more difficult,
but the summer is actually one of
the most beautiful places to be.
Our library is newly renovated.
It is a state of the
art research facility.
We hold guest quarters
at the Abbey guest house.
People can come and stay
and apply for fellowships
to reward their research.
We have nearly 50,000
reference books dedicated solely
to the research of manuscripts,
one of the largest
research reference libraries
in North America.
We are a library of libraries.
If you want to think about
our digital collections alone,
it's nearly 200 terabytes
of digital data
for those librarians
and those [inaudible].
They understand what this means.
This is a significant
collection which has
to constantly be updated
and preserved.
50 million images and counting.
Malta is about -- I would think
at this point is about 10 million
of those 50 million manuscripts,
a significant portion
of the collection.
135,000 microfilmed
manuscripts are currently housed
in our condition and in our vaults.
We tape everything
on our local drives.
We have local tape.
We backed up on a second server
and then we have a third location,
believe it or not, located in Utah
in a secret underground
granite vault where we keep all
of our digitized collections.
I believe, I think if -- this is
not to quote me exactly on this --
it can withstand a 50
megaton nuclear bomb.
So the world manuscript
culture is well preserved.
It's just outside of New York
-- not New York, Salt Lake City.
I'm being from New York
and thinking about that.
I shouldn't because
I grew up in Utah.
It's just outside of Salt Lake
City, and it's near where the Church
of Latter Day Saints, of course,
keeps its geneological records.
All of this, of course, is great,
but how do we actually make
this available to the public?
I'm very happy and very pleased
to announce that as of August
of this year, two years of
efforts have been finalized
where we can now start sharing
all of these collections with you.
This is a free online site, and it
will become the largest repository
if not the largest repository
of manuscripts in the world.
As of this morning,
I think I looked.
We have 5576 fully
digitized manuscripts located
in our virtual HMML.
If we think about this, over the
course of time if we are able
to complete our projects,
if we just stop the projects
that we are doing today, with
Timbuktu and every other manuscript,
this will be over 100,000 digitized
manuscripts located in virtual HMML.
I want to give a shout out here to
the Library of Congress [inaudible]
because of their work that
dates back almost 200 years now,
over 200 years in establishing
authorities because one
of the greatest things
that's happening
for our collections today is we are
now instituting both [inaudible]
and [inaudible] authority
control over our collections.
If you take a moment real quick, I'm
going to pop out of my presentation
and -- this is the live
site of virtual HMML,
and I'm currently logged in.
I'm going to just make it
just a little bit smaller.
That's too small.
A little bit bigger on
the screen for you to see.
We can go ahead and
just take a quick look
at reading room where
we do our search.
This is a very simple interface
that works on an elastic search,
and you can do very simple things
with this, and here I'm just going
to narrow my search
to digital collections
and type in the word Syria.
And you can see a fully
detailed view of all
of our Syria collections.
We only have 237 records in it,
but we'll be adding records
over the course of time.
If I open up the record,
you can see here
on the left loading the image
here, there's actually an early --
I love this one because it shows
you early manuscript image taken
in microfilm so that we can
compare what the manuscript looked
like when it was microfilmed over
50 years ago to the digital copy
that was taken less
than a decade ago.
[Inaudible] of course are
being put in on this level,
and if we go to the
full description,
you can start seeing
how we're moving
down into [inaudible] controls
and language both native
script and in English.
Our work here, of course, is so that
scholars can see the manuscript,
and take a good look at the
manuscript in their own home doing
as much research as possible.
This very elaborate system which
was put together by the Hill Museum
and Manuscript funded
by the [inaudible] Foundation
[inaudible] Foundation and money
from the Arcadia grant
is being put in place
so that we can realize the idea
that access should not be limited
to our own local site at
HMML but the recognition
that our responsibility is to the
people who open these collections
to us who might never
be able to travel
to the United States to see these.
We're talking about millions of
displaced people, people displaced
into Europe into Asia
within their own countries
who might never have access to
their own collections again.
This, of course, creates
other issues,
issues like how do we provide these
people with internet access itself,
but in the least this
free and open access
to these collections will
provide a repository for them
to see their culture as it
is transferred to the world.
It's not simply about an issue of
opening this up for scholarship.
I, myself and my colleague,
Dr. Ruff, have been working
on Latin fragments that
we've been finding in Syria,
fragments that date back to
the 11th century potentially.
We found a [inaudible] manuscript
in Aleppo believe it or not
of the Bible as a fragment
from the numbers I believe.
These fragments are really the
patrimony of humanity and not just
for scholars but for
the people themselves
because if I may just speak a
little bit extemporaneously here,
most of the work that we are
preserving are [inaudible] works
and religious works that are used by
the people in their churches today.
The fact is that these are not
simply repositories that we're going
and helping save, but
living, breathing libraries.
Most of the manuscripts
coming from the 18th,
19th and early 20th centuries.
I kind of want to conclude with
some of our kind of projects.
We hope to continue our
work over the next decade
in a variety of different places.
In Europe, we're opening
up places in the Balkins,
which of course was ravaged
by war during the 1990's.
Ukraine, of course, which is
undergoing conflict even though it's
in kind of a tense cease fire today.
In Malta, we'll be working
with University of Malta
and Heritage Malta in
the coming years we hope.
In the Middle East, we hope to
start working again in Lebanon,
in Syria if things hopefully soon,
we can go back to the country
and also in Yemen, which
is in a state of war today.
Afghanistan and India have
also opened their doors to us
and we are currently in discussions
with them in order to work there.
So our work is actually
expanding and it is an expansion
that is happening largely due
to the support of the public --
the Republic of Malta and
in particular for my sake
with the National Archives and
the National Library of Malta.
They've been helping me
personally over the last few years.
Its been a wonderful project.
I've been involved with
it for two years now.
This is actually my first public
presentation on HMML as a whole,
but I will go ahead and
end my discussion now
and to take your questions.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
I have a gentleman in the back.
I'll be honest with you.
I'm not really a specialist on what
might have happened in Central Asia
at the time and in the Middle East.
I do know that there's
a substantial collection
of Persian manuscripts both
in Northern India,
Afghanistan, Pakistan.
These collections are spectacular.
I believe the National Library
in Kabul itself has
the largest collection
of Persian manuscripts in the world.
I know that we're in discussions
in India right now to work on them.
Our previous work in India
was in southern India
with the Syria communities that
have migrated there previously.
But to the extent and size of
the Persian collections that are
in Northern India, I'm sorry,
I don't have that knowledge
with me now.
I would be surprise if they
were not substantial, however.
[ Inaudible ]
It's actually rather remarkable
-- if I can smile at my colleague,
[inaudible], Catholic
University at the moment.
It's a small 90 pound box.
We basically use a 20
megapixel Canon digital camera,
and a camera stand and two strobe
lights and a laptop computer
and a bunch of handmade handy
dandy get in and get out materials
which have been perfected
by my colleague,
Wayne Torborg [assumed spelling].
An entire studio itself, we can
move in and set up in what we do
in about an hour and a half?
More or less an hour and a half
we can set up an entire studio.
The studio itself cost I
believe less than $6000 depending
on the quality of the camera that
we use which is the major expense,
which are actually
becoming more affordable
as we improve in the technology.
So literally, it's a 3 foot by
2.5 foot box, weighs 90 pounds.
We can set up a studio in 1.5 hour,
takes about an hour to tear it down
and within 10, 15 minutes
of setting it up,
we can be fully digitizing
the collection.
It's a remote self-contained studio.
It's a simple Canon EOS
ESLR 20 megapixel camera.
For very large manuscripts,
I use a D810 Nikon 36.3
megapixels, but that's it.
It's that simple.
I wish it was more complicated,
and I can get into details.
But it really is that simple.
[ Inaudible ]
Fortunately, the European Union
has engaged in tremendous efforts
to provide for its own
color digitization projects.
One of the things that we've done
with our new system is
we have a direct link
where we can link our
older microfilm collections
to the new collections in Europe.
HMML's primary mission is to
work with endangered libraries
and libraries which are
vulnerable to climatic change
which is really one of the
primary instances in Malta.
Getting proper climate control
in an island environment
is extremely difficult.
The European libraries know -- I
mean, I work in Italy and because
of my work with the order
of the Knights of Malta,
we do work with European
collections.
And of course, in the Balkins
which we hope to open up this year.
But no, we won't be going back
in systematically doing
those collections
because they're doing it
themselves, and we don't need to.
The great projects of [inaudible] ,
for example, is a remarkable project
where you can see these
collections coming together
and archives portal Europe, and we
will be linking our older records
to their records as a part
of our project ourselves.
[ Inaudible ]
We, through HMML and St.
John's Abbey and the community
that supports HMML have been
providing assistance to refugees
in Iraq as part of our mission.
It would be irresponsible for us
to simply care about the libraries
and not the people themselves.
As much as it is important
for me to be caring --
taking care of tradition,
these are people
who are living in these camps today.
We certainly do what we
can within our institution.
One thing that should be stated here
is that all of our projects are run
by local people paid through HMML.
Therefore, in the least we're
providing employment opportunities.
We do not take our librarians and go
to these facilities to do the work.
We train them locally.
We provide the equipment and
then we support those efforts
as they continue.
So yes, we do engage in
with the best to our efforts
when we're able to do so.
Mostly in [inaudible]
is where our work is.
[ Inaudible ]
It's -- it's a big question,
and I would like to take this
question both with regard to Malta
and the world as a whole.
Let me talk about Malta first and
then the world because it's just --
simply because it's a little
bit more familiar to me.
If you want to think about this, and
I'm speaking here as a historian,
Malta is in the Mediterranean,
but it's also in an area
where earthquakes are prone
and it's close to [inaudible]
which could have some dramatic
effect upon the island.
I have to think to myself
every time I go there,
if I knew that I had 12
months to digitize something
on this island, what do I do?
You can make an argument that I
can go to the [inaudible] Cathedral
in Valetta where they have the
most precious [inaudible] produced,
these beautifully illuminated
Italian and French
in different areas for the
grand masters or do I go
to the national archives?
[Inaudible] which chronicle
primarily the slave trade in Malta
that took place during the
regime of the Knights in Malta.
And if I have 12 months,
what do I do?
Because on the one hand if I
preserve the great culture,
we can talk about these
great archistic achievements
of European civilization.
On the other hand, if
I take a decision not
to do the records [inaudible],
we might not know
that the slave trade had been
there or how prolific it was.
There are those people and families
that were there who might be looking
to those records to
trace their ancestry
after slavery was abolished in 1798.
It's a very big question.
It's not dissimilar to what it
confronts us as an institution
when we think about what we may or
may not be doing in the world today.
One can easily argue that one
could look at Latin America
or the Philippines or any other
place which may be vulnerable
to other forms of culture.
Violence, cu de tas.
We simply don't know.
People by and large have
attempted to approach us.
We do have within our own mission
statement to provide access
to collections which we already
have, meaning that the work
that we're doing in the Middle
East, this grand heritage
of the Middle East is part of the
European heritage and to think
of them as not collaborating
with each other is just
simply illogical fallacy.
All of the Greeks,
Syriac traditions,
all of the Armenian traditions
were in constant communication
with what was being
done in the Latin west.
There were constant communications.
My dissertation itself is about
a translation of a Syriac writer,
Isaac of Ninevah, whose works were
translated from Syriac into Greek
and then into Latin, brought into
Spain, translated into [inaudible].
Moving all the way
from Syria into Spain
at the 15th century
were [inaudible] hey,
this would be great to
read in [inaudible].
So to think about this as being
[inaudible] is a fundamental problem
for us.
We do have it within our mandate
to try to stay within our focus,
building upon the grand
riches of the collection while
at the same time we've never closed
our doors to anybody provided
that if it's the mission funding
can be found to support the project.
If anything, there's too much to do.
[ Inaudible ]
Sure.
[ Applause ]
>> Pierre Clive Agius: I'm
truly humbled to be here
and to see the work that you are
doing, and [inaudible] in the world
where the word on a piece
of paper is treasured,
is filed, it's recorded.
And listening to your presentation
and looking at the slides,
I could not avoid
but how [inaudible] it would
be if all this is lost.
We would not have records
of our failures,
of our mistakes, of our discoveries.
We would lose much of
humanity, would lose our love.
And at the same time, I
thought to myself, I said,
"How much work is going
on unnoticed?"
If you just think about
[inaudible] as you mentioned,
things which I myself did not know.
And which you are preserving
forever is gone.
I think there is a bit of
responsibility in this for all of us
for these people whop are
protecting our past for our future.
So I'm extremely grateful
and there's no other place
to say these words in here, and
I'm extremely proud and humbled
to be here in the Library
of Congress of all places
in Washington, D.C.
But Dr. [inaudible],
thanks to you, you
are the [inaudible].
I am just as grateful.
Dr. [inaudible], I can
only tell you how much
and how very sorry I came late.
I was -- but I would not have
missed this for my life believe me.
I learned a lot of things,
and greatly grateful for this.
[Inaudible] I have to mention you
[inaudible] because you are --
you embody the European
culture here.
So the Library of Congress
itself and [inaudible]
which are extremely
proud her in the U.S.A.
So once again, thank you very
much from the bottom of my heart
and you've taught me a lot this
Friday afternoon believe me.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> A few words [inaudible]
a few words.
Not a long speech.
Don't worry.
I don't to stop you seeing
the beautiful exhibition
in the [inaudible].
I thank you Dr. Gullo.
Really thank you.
You opened the door.
You know what I mean open the door?
And I know -- [inaudible]
embassy would be here,
is here now because they
[inaudible] they would like just
to explore another item about
library about preserving,
and I know the Embassy of Malta
has a lot of secrets under the door
because next time we really have to
approach that submarine archeology.
This is another item.
It's really, really interesting.
Do you know what?
When in Italy [inaudible] was
[inaudible] to do it a team instead
of events, events, events, events,
what doesn't make any sense.
We have to do a team
and the team that came
in my mind was protecting
our [inaudible]
and now this is the 22nd event that
we dedicated in D.C. to this team
and each one opened door.
It's unbelievable.
I will have -- next Tuesday, I will
have another exhibition in New York
with Columbia University dedicated
to protecting our [inaudible],
and [inaudible] is with us.
So we have only to
shake and we have only
to do something -- to do something.
It's incredible because you
mentioned before [inaudible].
You don't know many people
are really not protecting our
[inaudible] in our daily life.
They used to buy Ebay, items after
items [inaudible] shame on them.
Absolutely in our daily life.
We have to find out what
we can do in our daily,
daily life to protect our heritage.
I'm doing for example next year
I'm doing a project with a school,
first grade, second grade, third
grade in United States Maryland,
and I will ask to the boy and girls,
what do you like to
preserve in your life?
So the idea of preserving is
something that you have to put
like a seed in their mind and the
first response was a really, really,
really, really unbelievable.
I would like just to preserve
my [inaudible] coming home.
I'm going to preserve the
story of my grandma told me.
I would like to preserve smell,
smell -- perfume, story, book,
items, all of this is preserving.
All of this is our duty.
Just as you said, and as you
said for the next generation.
So [inaudible] think about --
contact me because
[inaudible] our team
of protecting our heritage will last
another three years so we have time
to explore it to open
door after door.
Thank you to all of you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.